[Music]
the title of Grandmaster was first
officially awarded in 1950 now in 2017
at the st. Louis Invitational that
tradition continues can you beat a
grandmaster
that's the question you need to ask
yourself here at the 2017 st. Louis
Invitational the GM and IM norms so
here's the skinny in the grandmaster
norm section there are three
grandmasters and seven international
masters the next step below to become a
grandmaster the IM must have a minimum
rating plus three grandmaster
performances or a norm as we call it so
in this tournament any one of the IMS in
this top section needs to earn six
points to earn that GM norm plus we're
also playing for first second and third
place overall that's what the
grandmasters are playing for after all
the IM norm section is mostly the same
three international masters and then
seven players who are not titled
international master all of those
players must also net six points to get
an IM norm except for st. Louis and Matt
Larson who because of the difference in
his rating has to earn six and a half
points more on that as we move on and of
course first second third so on and so
forth for the prizes we must say that it
is no guarantee that anybody not even
the winner of each field will earn a
norm that is a special occurrence but in
this tournament there is a $15,000 prize
fund the higher you score the more money
you make the scheduling for the st.
Louis Invitational is a little bit odd
one round on Friday two rounds on
Saturday two rounds on Sunday two rounds
on Monday one round on Tuesday and the
final round on a Wednesday
reason being that the feed a requires
that this be a six day tournament so to
span six days this is how you do it
I'm here with international master
Daniel gurevich he just won his game in
the fourth round and I know we only have
like 20 minutes until the next round so
we'll make it as brief as possible but
what were your feelings coming in today
four rounds four and what will be five
well that's a good question
really I'm just trying to get playable
positions that's my main goal going into
today okay so have you have you played
John bartholomae before your opponent in
this particular game I have had already
two games against him one of them I was
completely losing out of the opening and
really lucky to survive and somehow I
won because he got into time pressure
and the other one was a pretty solid
game where we played for a really long
time but it was just enjoying the end
okay so you're working toward your
second norm here in the GM field let's
take a look at the game and show us how
you pulled this one out
all right I thought that rugby seven in
any case was being too much for her on
one hand he does take the rooks off
which seems to make it easier for him to
draw but I think that here he
underestimated that in this line I have
this Bishop d6 move which prevents him
from coming Knight c7 and taking my pawn
and since this Knight is sort of cut off
on the edge of the board it's not really
clear how he can hold on to this pawn
other than what he did in the game so
for instance if he tries King F 1 still
hoping for me to take on b4 then he can
just take in 94 of course but then I
have this move e5 which looks a bit anti
positional weakening all these squares
but it prevents his concrete Knight d4
and after I went upon maybe he can get
some kind of fortress but it's
definitely risky for him
so he played 94 here which is what I
expected considering he was getting
quite low on time here I think he had
about 15 minutes left
so I traded here and going into this
position in my earlier calculations I
was of course hoping that I could get my
king over to d5 and put pressure on
these weak d4 and be four pawns but if
he can get a nice bone structure on the
Kings side put all of his pawns on leg
squares it's definitely not going to be
enough to win because just these two
weaknesses won't be too hard to defend
so that's why I chose g4 trying to fix
his pawns here a bit of a downside to
this decision is that he cannot
immediately start undermining with f3
and if I take he wins the butt on back
immediately of course so probably after
up three I have to play something like
h5 and still keep the these poems and
fixed on h2 and g3 but after King F - I
don't think that my winning chances are
too great most of my hope was connected
to his time pressure so I was quite
happy when he played f4 which doesn't
really challenge my pawn on g4 and it
essentially guarantees that all of his
pawns will be on dark squares for the
remainder of the sin King so at this
point I felt like it should be quite
close to winning but he still has a lot
of defensive resources I'm sure so I
spent a lot of time here trying to come
up with a good plan the natural idea of
just bringing my King into the center
which I was thinking about at first so I
just get my King on f5 but I can't
really make any progress bringing my
King to e4 and there isn't really any
chance to get it to d5 either so he's
going to bring the knight back into the
game and I was hoping that
some kind of idea with h4 eventually
what allow me to break through here but
eventually I figured out that it was
pretty unlikely that it would work so
here for instance maybe even 95 is okay
so later I stumbled upon this idea that
maybe I should just start bringing my
king to d5 it'll definitely take a long
time but there isn't that much that he
can do in this position to improve my
pawn on beef I was the only real
weakness but his knight as unfortunately
tied down to the defense of the b4 phone
so I played King f8 he started by
centralizing his King now he has to
prevent King d7 so of course he plays
Knight c5 sorry I have to keep going
around with King d8 unfortunately what I
was thinking at first with the Bishop c7
doesn't quite work because he can just
activate his Knight with 94 and start
attacking the b5 pawn and already it
doesn't work because after King d7 he
starts forking my pawns and I have
nothing I think so that's why I have to
go back with King d8 and in this
position the natural evaluation is that
white should be fine but the only
problem is that I have this f5 check
coming in and then I get the d5 square
for my King and that's exactly the dream
position I was hoping for so White's the
only chance really is to use the fact
that his King is more centralized and
that his pieces are quite active play f5
and after that things get really
complicated and i understand why john
avoided this in time pressure it's
impossible to calculate all of the
consequences I didn't quite know what
was going on either but it looks to me
like it should be a draw so here he has
to go Knight a6 King c4
King at 5:00 Bishop takes before can you
have six and now at this point my key
idea was of course if I just tried to
win the night with something like Bishop
C 3 and B 4 then he'll just give it up
and this pawn on h7 won't be enough to
win for sure but I saw that I have this
clever Bishop d6 move and I'm cutting
off his knight again and I think that's
what caused him to avoid this line in
the end but looking at this more in
depth it seems like even though my King
comes into c6 he gets some last moment
counter play with g4 and and then I
analyzed it for a little bit I think
that he's in time to give up the night
for the b5 pawn and then the H pawn is
the wrong color I can't do much to win
here so I think this was why it's last
chance to draw the game so he was
getting really really long time here
about two minutes left so he played 96
really quickly but now I get exactly
what I'm looking for so I still don't
have quite enough to finish the game
just by directly attacking the d4 and B
four pawns because these two weaknesses
he can still defend them pretty
effectively but he has a lot of other
problems he has to defend both the e 4
and C 4 squares otherwise if my King
comes in it can quickly prove disastrous
even if I give up my e6 pawn and the
other thing is that compared to the
position where my King was still stuck
on f5 this idea with h5 and H 4 really
becomes more effective so that's why
what I ended up playing h5 King III he's
defending against h4 for now but of
course I have time to prepare it anyway
and there's not much he can do to stop
it
so here I thought Bishop f6 I'll force
him to retreat to b3 and then play Age 4
and it's just this perfect domination
and I sort of missed that he has a
clever Knight a6 trick and he's starting
97 with a triple fork and of course if I
take on d4 not only is it a fork but he
can actually just go into the ponen game
I think either a 95 or a king d4
although here I thought maybe black
might have some chances to win by
getting his own passed pawn but in any
case it's too much complication to
really consider seriously when you have
complete domination on the board so I
just played Bishop d8 preventing the
spork I brought my King back I have all
the time in the world and now finally I
can start finishing up so h4 and the
problem here is that there is really no
good solution for white if he takes the
pawn then Bishop takes h4 and my bishop
will start attacking his position from
behind so for instance Knight c5 I can
just bring my King back to d5 and
already he has a lot of trouble
defending this pawn on b4 and eventually
he'll end up losing one of his bones and
then it's just game over
so that's why in this position he really
has to let my pawn come to h3 but it's
not any better because now I get this
third weakness on the kingside which is
the idea of getting Bishop h4 in and
then when he takes G 3 h2 there's no way
to stop the pawns so again he was forced
to play King III here to me Bishop h4
with King f2 but king c6 is already
putting him in 6 1 now he has to move
the knight which means that there's no
97 check and once there is no 97 check
he has to go either
Knight b3 here which allows King c4 or
what he did in the game King d3 but now
I finally get Bishop h4 and there is no
way to stop me from promoting so for
instance G takes h4 he ran out of time
here but even if he had enough time to
get through this he's exactly one tempo
short his knight can't get to f2 in time
so that was the end of the game I was
really happy to win from basically a
position where I had less than nothing
well thank you yeah thank you and thank
you for the analysis you know norm
opportunities and tournaments don't come
around too often what are your thoughts
coming into this event and what do you
see your perspective capabilities of
this event being well first of all I'm
really really grateful for this
opportunity it's an amazing tournament
and I couldn't miss it
good which do you have a certain game or
opponent you're looking forward to
coming up later I don't know I just want
to continue what I've been getting so
far which is playing alright and so far
I'm undefeated I don't know if I can
make it last but certainly I just want
to continue racking up the points and
playing good chest Daniel you're
certainly one of the players to watch
thank you for joining me and I'll let
you go because I know you got a game in
a few minutes let's take a look at the
standings after four rounds in the GM
norm section the grandmasters or the
gatekeepers you might call them the
dream crushers one of them is at the top
Grandmaster Ashwin from India a Webster
University favorite can players like
Daniel Gurevich earn a norm and maybe
overtake Ashwin here are the pairings
for the next two rounds in the
Grandmaster norm section by the time you
see this video round six will be the
round to watch it will be Monday morning
at 11 a.m.
Stevens urk John Burke to IMS in the GM
section both top scorers this will
probably be the game to watch we're
almost halfway through this event and in
the International Master norm field I'm
here with Erin Griffin ski who today
with the white pieces was able to defeat
international master from Costa Rica
area Santana congratulations on your
victory let's take a look at the game
and show us what happened
sure so I just played Bishop b6 and now
we see it's pretty clear the bishops
gonna be on d4 everything's gonna be
solidified I might be down a pawn the
pawn on d5 but it really doesn't matter
cuz the bishop is so strong before he
can never dislodge it and here I think
Black has to play King e7 or at least he
should because he needs to prevent
Bishop d7 I don't think he should
allowed smooth because we'll see why
after Bishop d6 yeah oh yeah that's what
he played Bishop d6 and I think that's
bad because after Bishop d4 now King e7
is not working anymore because I just
had Bishop f6 and then if Chievo should
be six
five so the thing is after Bishop c2
obviously trying to return but
unfortunately I'm just gonna play there
now we see why the king should have been
on you seven first because now when the
bishops gets to d7 he can't really deal
with Bishop c6 which will win the d5
pawn and soon after probably more plants
cuz his Bishop is probably not gonna
want to be stuck there forever so but
the problem is let's say Bishop D one
Bishop c6 yeah and so in order to
protect this Pawnee sto King e6 but then
I have Bishop e8 and it turns out my
pawn Shack rifice has kind of worn a lot
of fruit because I'm winning my pawn
back but it's this pawn which is a very
nice pawn to have because then I'm gonna
have a past G pond and he did we again
we see the pawn on d5 is is an extra
pawn but it's not helping him at all
so Bishop g4 take Bishop e7 there's
major seventh and here I really thought
I was just gonna win like I thought it
was game over but I completely missed at
this point yeah so here I thought King
g3 protecting the pawn because if g6 he
has bishop takes a check or so I don't
need that King g3 Bishop d8 and here
yeah g6 was very bad move I completely
missed Bishop e6 which was rather sad
it's because after Bishop e6 that's well
that's not clear I can't play g7 I don't
want to take it so I had to play Bishop
e8 and they worked eventually but I
don't think this should allow this after
Bishop d8 instead of g6
maybe just king f4 possibly cuz then i
have there should be five check ideas
driving his king further away and then
and then g6 cuz he'll his king will have
to go this way otherwise d5 saying so
this this king f4 is probably just
easily winning but i made my life hard
as king of g6 there should be six and
yeah i was annoying so I had to play
Bishop e8 King e7 it's I mean it's still
difficult for black and it's still hard
for him but I think I I was too too fast
with this move should have spent more
time
Bishop c6 check King f2 and here he
makes a blunder but he didn't have any
time here I'd like maybe 30 seconds and
he played King d6 which just loses
instead of that maybe just Bishop d6 I
think you might still be able to hold it
draw here because his King is very close
to the past Jeep on my king cannot come
in at all because his bishops control
all of the squares and my two bishops
alone as long as he covers all his
points I think it might just be equal so
I don't know what the engine says but
yeah I don't see a lot for me it was a
little bit annoying for sure but anyway
fortunately who it's because the g6 was
so bad but he returned the favor II
played King d6 but and then after Bishop
a4 he has a big problem because his King
is now too far from the Jeep on which
means he's gonna lose his h5 pawn after
Bishop d1 and I'm gonna take on aged
five and then I'm gonna be winning
because the two of two pawns is too much
so the problem now is he can't defend
the pawn with his bishop because the
Jeep on runs and his King really needed
to be closer that's why I said leave the
King on e7 he should be okay because for
example Bishop d6 Bishop a4 you can just
play Bishop g4 and there's no g7 because
just king of 7 right check King g8
Bishop c6 c7
it should be six games dude I think used
to draw my bishops can't win and by
themselves his bishops control all the
squares so yeah if this sort of happened
it would have been quite upsetting
because before I played g6 back here I
knew I was winning so I just had to play
King at four yeah so anyway but that's
nice King bee six pitch before and now I
don't think we really need any comments
I was able to win the pawn and then once
I wouldn't respond he's too fast pawn
sir here here he played Bishop d6 and at
the same time he flagged but I was just
losing anyway I'm just gonna move the
bishop maybe here even push the
h-bonding so he flagged in that game
yeah he put he was like hesitating he
knew he had three seconds and he was you
know gonna make the move you know how
that goes you kind of forget how fast
seconds tick away and so he played
Bishop d6 but at the same time he ran
two zeros okay well right now you stand
two out of the three necessary norms to
your credit and also your 15 points away
from the 2400 threshold that is also
required for the International Master
title itself so what do you see you can
accomplish both in this tournament but
what do you look at is what's your
outlook on this tournament well it would
be nice if I got consuls both I'm just
you know playing and I don't know I'm
not really pushing too hard I'm just
kind of keep the game going and
eventually my opponents well clearly
they end up making mistakes it seems
like and I don't I guess in this
tournament I'm not not making such such
critically mistakes where I lose I
clearly made a mistake in this game but
not enough for me loser which has been a
draw in bad
yeah so it's I guess it's a nice
tournament um if I don't win any more
games I think I can still get the norm I
think if I draw my last whatever how
many games we have I think I might still
get there but even if even if I don't
get the rating I'm not too worried about
it should come eventually I'm just
trying to get at this point neither you
nor I knew that for certain the number
of points you had to get we'll have to
find that out to get the norm so that
says to me yeah you know let's just play
chess yeah I mean I'm not really well I
didn't I don't even care how many points
I need to get to know I'm just trying to
do that well I wish you the best area
thank you for joining me and let's take
a look at the standings after four
rounds midway through were just about in
the international master section in the
IM norm section erin grab in ski and
justin Wang are at the top of the
leaderboard both of these players are
looking to norm and as grab in ski said
get that extra 15 points fee day to earn
the IM title on Sunday night these two
players will meet over the board but by
the time you see this video that game
will probably be finished so on Monday
morning round six the game to watch
we'll probably be Erin grim in ski
against any weighing the women's
international master catch all the games
live move by move as they happen on
chess 24 and us chess champs calm Monday
Tuesday Wednesday at 11 a.m. Central
Plus Monday at 5 p.m. another round in
there as well until next time this has
been Simon so long from the Show Me
State